you say cyrus et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau coup de fil ce qui ne tue pas te
rend plus fort encore dieu est mort bref
c'est des citations vous avez sûrement
déjà entendu et ça tombe bien parce
qu'on va attaquer l'un des épisodes les
plus demandés depuis la création de
l'émission
il s'agit du surhomme près des chewing
nietzsche est un philosophe allemand
alors il a deux particularités
déjà au niveau de son nom il a tout les
consonnes dedans donc pour l'orthographe
c'est plutôt simple un vous mettez tout
ensuite au niveau du physique c'est quoi
cette moustache dans le mec a une
moustache plus épaisse que ses cheveux
on dirait un ballet quoi j'adore les
saucisses de francfort et irish bon
chien
il a étudié la philologie c'est l'étude
d'une langue à partir des textes il est
devenu lui même professeur de philo
puis le moment mais il n'a pas pu
continuer longtemps parce qu'ils avaient
des mots tête à répétition genre hyper
violent donc ils arrêtent à 30 50 et là
pendant dix ans il donne tout ce qu'il a
et publié la majeure partie de saison
sachant qu'à ce moment il passe déjà sa
vie dans une grande solitude et la à 45
ans sa maladie le plonge dans un état
critique
laurent mode légumes pendant dix ans à
rome auprès de riches ou diplôme un vase
en rend plus fort a loupé un ouais ouais
avec philosophie de nietzsche critique
le christianisme parce que pour lui ça
mais la terre en infériorité par rapport
au ciel et en plus ça nous demande de
dépasser ce qui nous semble important
sur terre sauf qu'en faisant ça on se
détourne un petit peu de la vie elle
même
en plus de ça c'est ce que je vous
disais dans un trou pour lui dieu est
mort alors c'est un petit pas mal de
choses cette mort de dieu déjà ça veut
pas dire que plus personne ne croit plus
en dieu c'est pas ça ça veut juste dire
que nos valeurs ne repose plus sur la
foi or l'héritage notre moral en tout
cas chez nous il est judéo chrétien
c'est à dire qu'il vient de tout ce qui
est tu ne tueras point et c'est donc si
on perd notre foi et 20 le système va
finir par se rompre et on assiste du
coup à une dévalorisation des valeurs
supérieures comme les valeurs de justice
liberté moralité etc
on perd on vient d'apprendre que dieu
est mort m'enfin ça fait 40 ans que j'ai
donné ma vie pour le seigneur je sais je
sais bref les valeurs du coup moi je le
perds député finir pokémon
troublant cette histoire qu'on continue
thomas s'il te plaît la conséquence de
sas et le nihilisme et c'est pas le fait
de croire en rien comme beaucoup
pourrait le penser
là on chez nietzsche il ya deux formes
de nihilisme il ya d'abord le nihilisme
passif c'est celui qui considère que la
vie n'a pas trop sens donc ils se
demandent à quoi bon c'est celui qui n'a
pas la force de croire en autre chose
quand son propre bonheur tu vois donc
c'est un pessimiste et ce nihilisme là
il faut le combattre
mais c'est dieu est mort et qu'on va
perdre nos valeurs il va autant pour les
perdre parce qu'on les remplace par
quelque chose ce que nietzsche appelle
le nihilisme actifs et va nous falloir
un petit peu dette pour engraisser ses
valeurs ouais ouais on va remplacer les
valeurs croyait à une dévalorisation
voilà exactement tu vas tu vends du
ventoux two way des oignons la justice
par contre dalcourt non prudence a du
coup à vouloir revaloriser la vie
elle-même revaloriser lettre il va
vouloir rectifier si tu veux cette
infériorité de la terre par rapport au
ciel qu'on a vu tout à l'heure dans le
christianisme est en fait il se rend
compte que chaque être a une énergie en
lui qui est moteur qui le pousse et va
partir de ça c'est la volonté de
puissance vous souvenez du conatus de
spinoza alors le conatus c'est l'effort
de persévérance dans son être ces genres
par exemple la plante qui pousse le
cheval qui galope l'homme qui pense ou
qui désirent la volonté de puissance de
nietzsche ses très proches
sauf qu'on n'est pas dans la
persévérance de son être on est dans le
dépassement
c'est à dire que le but n'est pas de
conserver sa puissance mais c'est de
l'augmenter indéfiniment et si on va
l'incarnation de cette volonté de
puissance la plus haute la limite vers
plus infinie pour les matins on arrive
au surhomme or pourtant j'ai bien j'ai
bien suivi la notice mais je suis pas
sûr que ce soit la bonne manière pour
dépasser mon être je suis pas sûr quand
tu ne verras le ridicule ne tue pas ce
qui te tue pas te rend plus fort donc
peut-être que le ridicule te rend plus
fort j'avoue j'avais pas pensé à ça et
là vous en pensez quoi
alors le surhomme c'est pas du tout ce
qu'on vient de voir dans le summum c'est
un idéal pour l'homme du coup l'homme
c'est la corde tendue entre la tête et
le surhomme c'est à dire que tout ce qui
est naze en toi c'est la bête c'est
l'animal est ce que tu veux attendre ce
que tu dois atteindre c'est le surhomme
alors faut pas du tout le voir comme
superman ou instruction naturellement du
tout c'est quelque chose de très concret
en voulant être un surhomme
l'homme se surpasse et pour nietzsche
c'est ce qui fait de lui un homme autre
chose d'important le surhomme
si tu veux il désire pas un monde idéal
à un monde qui pourrait arriver qui
pourraient exister non le surhomme
il veut et il concentre ce monde notre
monde et du coup ils en désire même le
retour c'est quelque chose qu'on appelle
l'éternel retour en fait nietzsche dit
qu il faut vivre sa vie de telle sorte
que l'on puisse souhaiter de la vivre
indéfiniment
c'est un rouleau avec un ipod alors je
te laisse imaginer avec la vie après ça
peut être très cool pour continue thomas
s'il te plaît mais ça peut être aussi
très nul mais non ça n'a pas duré
longtemps allait pencher bond en avant
voilà donc ce qu'il faut c'est voir
cette idée de l'éternel retour comme une
épreuve à passer pour savoir si on sera
proche ou pas du souverain le surhomme
c'est donc l'accomplissement de la
volonté de puissance et de l'éternel
retour on peut voir le surhomme comme
une destination la vente et puissance
comme notre moteur et l'éternel retour
comme la route que l'on prend alors
attention le soir il va donc nous aider
à remplacer les valeurs dont on vous
parlait mais il remplace pas vraiment
dieu parce que le sur abstrait il n'est
pas au delà de notre réalité
le surhomme c'est un idéal concret en
tout homme sur terre mais maman c'est à
dire qu'il existe vraiment superman et
bien sûr mon chéri bien toi au plus
profond de ton être cool
après cette conversation jason est mort
suite à une chute violente de plusieurs
étages croyant pouvoir voler son camp
sans suite s'écrase
à plusieurs reprises par des camions
poubelles et le bus numéro 128 et
d'ailleurs si tu veux augmenter ta
volonté de puissance et de dépasser je
te conseille d'être abonné à la chaîne
et de rater aucun épisode à venir
j'espère en tout cas que le sua bonnici
maintenant plus clair pour vous vous
envoie du love et de la piste merci
aussi jonathan derrière le blog un
philosophe qui d'ailleurs alors je vous
parle normalement a sorti un an quand un
article sur nietzsche ici et qui est
spécieuse de niche qui m'a permis d'être
sûr de la qualité de cet autre chose
souvent quand je parle de nietzsche on
évoque le nazisme en fait ce qui s'est
passé c'est que les nazis et utiliser
nietzsche pour défendre leur idéologie
notamment avec la vidéo du forum par
exemple en parlant d'un surhomme
physique alors que nietzsche finalement
avait plus eu l'idée d'un surhomme
intellectuelle alors évidemment le
nazisme c'est quelque chose qui aurait
condamné milk par exemple ni tes potes
avec wagner et l'arrêté des potes à tout
moment où celui ci est devenu voulait
pas de me suivre sur les réseaux sociaux
aussi facebook twitter cela chat
les trois j'utilise différemment je fais
tout c'est plus vrai que de temps en
temps une rustine user comme ça et 104
plaintes le voilà non je suis pas sûr
28 le gard le ridicule ne tue pas ce qui
tue pas rend plus fort
du coup
ce qui rend ridicule